bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre dans
filet cool l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition
Skywest est déserté par les commerces de
plusieurs années mais pourraient
renaître de ses cendres à la société
propriétaire à Mersen aurait un nouveau
projet pour le centre commercial de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans les
Yvelines toujours de nouvelles
initiatives sont mises en place à
l'occasion du Mois de l'économie sociale
et solidaire cette thématique encore peu
développée sur le département prend de
l'ampleur le siège social en France du
groupe international d'euro est suédois
mais il est basé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux Jérôme Arnaud le
PDG de Dour et français il gère le
groupe de ces bureaux de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous l'avons
rencontré rappelez-vous enfin dans notre
entretien de cette semaine nous
parlerons de l'Association des
mampeneurs des Yvelines l'association
organise son premier salon le 7 et le 8
novembre à Versailles nous en parlerons
avec angelajotic bonsoir vous êtes
membre donc de l'Association des
Yvelines nous reviendrons avec vous sur
l'action de l'association ainsi que son
concept mais avant cela passons en revue
l'actualité de la semaine
je vous disais à l'instant il y a
peut-être du nouveau pour le projet
Skywest le centre commercial de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est en tout
cas le souhait du propriétaire amerson
qui avait investi 70 millions d'euros
avec la société Codic en 2011 dans le
centre alors rien n'est encore
officialisé mais il existe bien un
projet de refonte du centre commercial
implanté à Montigny-le-Bretonneux un
reportage de Catherine zulato 2001 un
centre commercial portant le nom de
fiesta devait sortir de terre à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux un centre
commercial novateur pour l'époque dédiée
aux loisirs finalement il n'en sera rien
à la place Skywest est inauguré en
grande pompe en 2005 cela se veut un
lieu tourné vers les enseignes haut de
gamme quelques années plus tard les
rideaux de la plupart des enseignes sont
baissés il reste encore locomotive UGC
mais le centre est bien triste le projet
carré privé ouest dédié au luxe à prix
cassé est abandonné en 2013 un nouveau
dossier serait sur les rails même si
c'est un peu trop tôt pour
l'officialiser pour le propriétaire
amerson on ne se cache plus vraiment
oui il y a un projet sur Skywest il y a
plusieurs agences qui travaillent
aujourd'hui sur ce projet de
développement on ne peut rien dire de
précis puisque il y a plusieurs pistes
étudiées mais je peux vous rassurer sur
le fait qu'il y a beaucoup de monde à
travailler sur la restructuration
globale de Skywest qui sera un projet en
tout cas complémentaire de l'espace
Saint-Quentin pour une volonté de
dynamiser cette ce belle édifice c'est
trop tôt d'annoncer tout de suite
loisirs culture mais en effet ça serait
intéressant de d'étudier cette
perspective là un projet donc qui n'est
pas sans rappeler le concept initial
fiesta un centre commercial tourné vers
les loisirs et l'offre culturels je
crois qu'on a perdu beaucoup de temps
pour des raisons de de concurrence de
rivalité et en tout cas on revient à la
base à l'essentiel et aujourd'hui bien
on se dirige vers ce qui a toujours été
finalement la conception de Jean-Luc
Solal à l'époque c'est-à-dire faire un
centre tourner vers la culture et les
loisirs
le nouveau Skywest devra trouver sa
place parmi une offre concurrentielle
importante wine nation Paris qui vient
par exemple d'ouvrir ses portes au
Clayes-sous-Bois et qui cherche encore
sa clientèle on se demande s'il y a pas
justement des surfaces commerciales un
peu trop nombreuses c'est des questions
qu'on peut se poser il y a quand même
des inquiétudes en tant que chambre de
commerce on peut avoir que des
inquiétudes si justement si ces centres
de commerciaux ne se développent pas la
société amersson veut encore rester
discrète tout juste sait-on qu'en ce
mois de novembre un salon professionnel
pourrait être le lieu de signature
d'accord pour de futurs anciennes
intéressés le projet complet pourrait
être dévoilé début 2015
le mois de novembre est depuis 7 ans
l'occasion d'une grande campagne pour
mettre en lumière l'économie sociale et
solidaire alors parmi les principes de
cette économie on retrouve l'intérêt
collectif le fonctionnement démocratique
le développement durable ou encore
l'innovation sociale plusieurs
événements ont lieu cette semaine dans
les Yvelines notamment à Versailles ou à
Rambouillet et à Rambouillet pardon ou
la thématique est en plein développement
William elle et Anthony Rech
réintégrer le monde de l'emploi et de
l'entreprise par le biais d'une
association dans les Yvelines les
Jardins de Cocagne à Magny-les-Hameaux
où l'entreprise envie à Trappes
participent à cette dynamique de
l’économie sociale et solidaire
développer ses clauses d'insertion
véritablevier pour l'intégration des
personnes en difficulté dans les marchés
publics et privés est un thème
primordial à Versailles le CDAI du 78
souhaite sensibiliser les différents
acteurs de l'économie sur ce sujet je
pense que c'est intéressant que les
structures de l'insertion par l'activité
économique se fasse mieux connaître soit
plus lisible il faut qu'on les considère
aussi par certains côtés comme des
entreprises des entreprises qui sont
installées au niveau local qui
développent une activité qui génère un
chiffre d'affaires qui développe de la
richesse sur le territoire qui salarie
des personnes dans les Yvelines 8,2% des
établissements emploi du personnel dans
le cadre d'une économie sociale et
solidaire ce qui représente 3170
employeurs développer l'emploi aidé dans
les différents secteurs d'activité
mais aussi plus globalement cette
économie c'est l'objectif que c'est fixé
le réseau à venir 78 né en 2013 il
regroupe la BGE 78 professions sport 78
Yvelines active et y quatre associations
du département c'est quelque chose qui
est en devenir dans les Yvelines
effectivement il y a certains
départements où il y a déjà plein
d'actions où ça tourne mais une telle
préfiguration de réseau comme celui-ci
est une première en France il en existe
nul par ailleurs et on voit que les gens
ont envie de faire donc c'est quelque
chose qui va prendre son envol et
prendre un réel essor depuis un an elles
ont mené des actions en parallèle mais
concertées
financières et de ressources humaines on
a réalisé en tout si collectif sur
l'année 2014
ces formations ont eu un certain succès
en tout cas toutes les missions locales
des Yvelines ont été intéressées se sont
inscrites à une ou plusieurs de ses
formations le réseau avenir 78 veut
intensifier son action et les
possibilités sont nombreuses en 2011
selon l'Observatoire Régional de
l'économie sociale et solidaire de
l'Île-de-France 32 920 personnes étaient
employées dans les Yvelines dans ce
cadre ce qui représente 6,6% des emplois
du département
et la semaine prochaine à l'occasion de
du Mois de l'économie sociale et
solidaire nous reviendrons sur
l'entreprise envie attrape un bel
exemple de réussite dans ce secteur
innovation maintenant le sous-traitant
tiède industrie récompensé pour son
action innovante au salon du mid-est
implanté à vélizy-villac Industrie est
une entreprise de 50 salariés se
spécialiste de l'injection et du
soufflage vient de recevoir le trophée
2014 du salon international
international mid-est dans la catégorie
réalisation exemplaire pour l'invention
de flotteurs soufflé pour centrale
solaire flottante alors le mid-est je le
rappelle c'est le salon international de
la sous-traitance industrielle il se
tient jusqu'au 7 novembre au Parc des
Expositions de Paris Nord Villepinte
et lui n'est pas récompensée c'est le
théâtre de Saint-Quentin des
irrégularités ont été constatées dans
les contes du théâtre il doit faire état
de toutes les contributions en nature
supportées par la casquille c'est la
chambre régionale des comptes qui le lui
demande elle vient de rendre un rapport
sur la question sur la gestion du
théâtre entre 2006 et 2013 et fait état
de quatre recommandations elle évoque
des lacunes comptables qui altèrent
l'appréciation de la gestion de
l'établissement la chambre régionale des
comptes indiquait que la subvention
versée par la Communauté d'Agglomération
était supérieure d'un tiers à la moyenne
observée dans les autres scènes
nationales
et du théâtre nous passons maintenant au
cinéma cette semaine le cinéma UGC à
Saint-Quentin fêter ses dix ans il est
classé 13e dessiné des cinémas UGC de
France en terme de fréquentation
l'établissement connaît un certain
succès au début du projet les petites
salles de proximité craignaient cette
concurrence directe de ce gros cinéma
disons après quelle la situation un
reportage de William l et Catherine
dulato
avec un million 300 000 entrées par an
lui essai de 50 ans en Yvelines a réussi
son pari fait il y a 10 ans malgré la
conjoncture difficile pour les salles de
cinéma en France le nombre d'entrées
dans les multiples étant constant
augmentation ils ont enregistré 120
millions 600 000 entrées en 2010 s'en
sortent mieux que peut-être les petites
sales ou la moyenne d'exploitation mais
voilà actuellement on est dans une
conjoncture économique compliquée où les
gens doivent arbitrer entre différentes
sorties ben voilà en ce moment les
agrites avec des loisirs ou aller au
cinéma c'est peut-être un petit peu
moins de cinéma en ce moment peut-être
bien que le nouveau tarif moins de 14
ans nous a fait beaucoup de bien et
amener beaucoup de fréquentations en
plus l'arrivée de l'UGC en 2004 a
fortement impacté les salles de cinéma
de plus petites capacités sur le
territoire les yeux d'Elsa à Saint-Cyr
l'école a vu sa fréquentation baissée
avec une moyenne de 35000 entrées il y a
10 ans contre 25000 aujourd'hui attrape
le grenier à celle a aussi été touché
même si ce cinéma de quartier reste
attractif on s'en sort très très bien
voilà c'est vrai qu'on fait 25000 ans
très par an lui j'essaye d'en faire
c'est pas comparable mais en même temps
on a une salle et on n'a pas du tout les
mêmes les mêmes enjeux et puis on n'est
pas tout à fait dans le même dans le
même créneau l'objectif a toujours été
de faire de l'arrêter à toujours été de
faire de l'éducation au cinéma de
travailler avec la population donc notre
objectif ce n'est pas forcément de de
faire les films les plus rentables et de
faire le maximum d'entrée on veut de la
diversité on veut montrer aussi des
films qui sont pas vus partout ailleurs
même constat pour le ciné 7 à Élancourt
- 20% d'entrée depuis l'arrivée du
multiplex mais la salle de proximité a
su se renouveler doté d'un troisième
écran elle enregistre environ 100 000
entrées par an le point fort de ces
petites salles leurs tarifs qui en
disant on peut augmenter le prix d'une
place moyenne est de 6 euros à
Saint-Cyr-l'École 5 euros à Élancourt et
trap 5,60 à Montigny contre 10,50 € à
l'UGC un avantage mise en avant par les
salles de proximité on a une carte
d'abonnement qui est commune ça je le
précise à Élancourt
trappe Les Clayes-sous-Bois et Fontenay
fleuri qui permet d'acheter 10 places de
cinéma pour 43 euros donc ça ça marche
très très bien les gens s'y retrouvent
beaucoup c'est pas nominatif c'est
valable un an on peut aller dans les
quatre lieux sans aucun problème
s'associe pour proposer des tarifs plus
avantageux et une offre de films plus
large c'est la dynamique choisie par les
salles de proximité de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour se
différencier de quoi plaire aux nombreux
cinéphiles Yves Linois en 2010 5
millions 512 000 entrées ont été
enregistrées sur les 100 visages du
département
et pour ses 10 ans l'UGC propose des
places à tarif réduit 5 euros un tarif
unique pour ces spectateurs du 4 au 14
novembre je vous propose maintenant de
passer à notre entretien de la semaine
alors je vous disais en titre nous
allons parler des même preneurs des
Yvelines angelajotic vous êtes je le
rappelle membre de cette association les
mêmes preneurs et vous êtes également
entrepreneur alors tout d'abord
expliquer moi qu'est ce que c'est que
cette association comment elle
fonctionne quel est son but dites-moi un
peu plus alors c'est un réseau féminin
d'entraide on va dire c'est
classiquement au départ c'est à dire
mettre en relation des jeunes mamans et
des jeunes chefs d'entreprise pour
permettre de confronter nos différentes
expériences et s'entraider autant que
possible mais effectivement la
particularité du réseau mamponneur c'est
que nous mettons l'accent sur le fait
que nous sommes tout à la fois maman et
chefs d'entreprise est-ce qu'il fait la
particularité de du réseau même preneur
alors c'est une association qui est
nationale il y a des antennes dans toute
la France comment est né cette
association c'est parti en fait un peu
de liquide alors c'est parti d'une jeune
femme s'appelle Céline feigner qui a
quitté son travail de salarié pour
monter sa propre entreprise et elle
s'est rendue compte assez rapidement que
elle se retrouvait souvent seule face à
à travailler seul mais qu'à la fois elle
s'est rendu compte qu'elles étaient
trois ou quatre d'au moins dans son
quartier à être dans la même situation
elles ont décidé de se rencontrer et
elles ont lancé au tout départ le
premier mamcafé qui allait ensuite
donner lieu à toutes nos réunions
mensuelles mais le premier même café
c'est tenu dans le café en bas de chez
elle à 4 ou 5 pour ensuite se développer
et fonder le réseau des ma preneurs au
niveau national et vous en fait au
bureau des Yvelines alors combien vous
êtes vous savez combien de temps comment
fonctionnez-vous qu'est-ce que vous
organisez le bureau des Yvelines est le
bureau dans lequel il y a le plus de
membres nous sommes à peu près une
quarantaine on se réunit une fois par
mois généralement le lundi matin pour
permettre à chacune de pouvoir se
libérer et venir au moment où les ou les
enfants sont à l'école a priori ou en
tout cas soit occupé et on a donc un
bureau où on se on se réunit une fois
par mois pour parler des des
problématiques que l'on peut avoir mais
aussi pour aborder les différents sujets
de notre activité de nos activités en
tant que chef d'entreprise alors vous
abordez ces problématiques vous échangez
je pense entre vous est-ce que vous
organisez aussi des réunions il y a des
conférences je sais pas des ateliers
peut-être alors un effet chacun de nos
mamcafés donc il y a lieu de les lundi
matin tournent autour de plusieurs
moments il y a d'une part une
présentation une intervention de
quelqu'un de une des adhérents ou bien
quelqu'un qui vient de l'extérieur pour
aborder une problématique autour de la
comptabilité la création d'entreprise
les paiements les conditions générales
de vente et des tas d'autres choses ou
bien les référencesments sur Internet
les choses comme ça donc des
problématiques que nous rencontrons
chacune il y a ensuite un moment
d'échange où chacune fait part de ses
besoins si elle rencontre un obstacle a
besoin d'une information il y a un
moment d'échange on essaie aussi de
s'automotiver avec chacune notre good
news de du mois on essaie chacune de
venir avec une bonne nouvelle pour se
donner de l'automotivation entre entre
nous toutes et puis ça se termine
généralement par un repas ou
effectivement ça nous permet de mieux
nous connaître parce que c'est en se
connaissant vraiment bien qu'on peut
vraiment s'entraider et prendre toute la
dimension de l'association alors il
existe déjà des clubs d'entrepreneurs au
féminin pour les femmes pourquoi là
justement un club une association
réservée aux mamans spécificité un peu
en fait c'est surtout un état d'esprit
les mêmes preneurs c'est-à-dire que
l'idée c'est que nous sommes toutes des
mamans d'une part et nous avons toute
une vocation à réussir notre activité
professionnelle simplement on cherche
juste équilibre entre vie personnelle et
vie professionnelle et c'est ce qui fait
vraiment la différence après
effectivement les thématiques qui sont
abordées sont surtout professionnelles
mais simplement il y a aussi dans le
mode d'organisation de l'association il
n'y a jamais des réunions networking qui
commence à 18h le soir il n'y a jamais
de de réunions ou de rendez-vous qui
déborde sur les week-ends alors ce
week-end est exceptionnel puisque nous
avons notre salon qui qui continue
jusqu'à samedi mais d'une manière
générale on essaie de se réunir et de se
voir et de se rencontrer uniquement aux
heures ou les enfants sont occupés alors
vous-même vous êtes entrepreneur vous
avez mis en place un site internet pour
la garde d'enfants en horaires décalé
c'est ça c'est tout à fait ça ça
s'appelle nounou décalé.com alors qui
vous faites partie de ce réseau quels
sont les autres mamans qui font partie
de ce réseau qui est le professionnelle
alors c'est très divers et variés comme
on dit on n'a pas simplement des des
mamans qui font des gâteaux et qui
vendent leurs gâteaux loin de là et même
si c'est très louable d'avoir cette
activité on a des professionnels qui
sont aussi bien des psychologues des
créatrices de jeux éducatifs pour
enfants des personnes qui donnent des
cours culinaires aussi pour les enfants
ça tourne un peu autour des enfants
c'est vrai mais nous avons aussi une
psychologue une gestionnaire de
patrimoine une personne qui prépare
notre retraite une personne qui a une
activité autour de des producteurs
locaux dans les Yvelines enfin voilà une
rédactrice une idée triste
les profils sont vraiment très variés
dans la quarantaine de personnes je
crois qu'il n'y a personne qui est deux
fois la une activité alors justement il
y a l'entraide dans votre association
est-ce que voilà le fait d'avoir
rencontré ces différentes femmes
entrepreneuses entrepreneurs est-ce
qu'il y a des je sais pas des choses qui
sont nées justement de ces rencontres
oui il y a forcément une synergie déjà
parce que en mettant ensembles en commun
toutes nos compétences il y a forcément
de l'entraide qui se crée entre les unes
et les autres forcément moi qui incite
pour la garde d'enfants d'horaire décalé
j'ai 40 ambassadrice dans les Yvelines
puisque dès l'une ou l'autre a besoin ou
entend parler de quelqu'un elle met en
avant mon site et de la même manière si
je sais que j'ai quelqu'un qui cherche
une conseillère en image je sais qu'il
lui recommandé ou si quelqu'un cherche
pour de la confection je sais qui
recommandait donc effectivement le fait
que il y a vraiment un état d'esprit de
on se serre les coudes et on se on
s'entraide et qui fait que on va
forcément se recommander les unes les
autres alors j'aimerais venir revenir
avec vous sur le salon qui se dérouler
demain et après-demain oui une première
alors pourquoi justement voilà avoir
décidé de faire un salon alors en fait
l'idée était venue d'une part de nous
faire connaître parce que c'est vrai que
c'est un réseau qui existe depuis 2009
environ et depuis deux trois ans dans
les Yvelines mais finalement on est peu
connu donc l'idée c'est de faire parler
nous et pourquoi pas attirer de
nouvelles adhérences et susciter de
nouvelles vocations pour que de
nouvelles personnes viennent nous
rejoindre et puis de manière aussi de
montrer l'étendue de nos activités et
montrer un peu ce que chacune sait faire
donc on va on se rend demain c'est où
est-ce que c'est exactement alors c'est
à Versailles parce que la mairie de
Versailles nous a gentiment prêté une
salle c'est sale c'est la salle excusez
moi ta sans cours rue Pierre Lescaut et
il y a différentes activités on peut
venir bien sûr pour nous rencontrer nous
poser toutes les questions
qui vous viennent à l'esprit mais
également pour y faire du shopping les
mamans qui ont une activité de vente de
produits cette fois-ci pourront vendre
sur le sur leur propre stand il y a
également des ateliers on peut par
exemple nous avons une de nos membres
qui fait des massages donc elle
proposera des ateliers de massage il y a
également des tables rondes nous allons
animer deux tables ronds d'une vendredi
une samedi pour évoquer justement les
problématiques de comment créer sa son
entreprise avec boire et des bois de la
création d'entreprise et puis également
une autre thématique une autre table
ronde sur les la vie personnelle et vie
professionnelle comment allier les deux
donc il y a différentes choses à venir y
faire dans ce salon viens c'est un bel
événement j'espère que beaucoup s'y
rendront merci Angie d'être venu sur
notre plateau nous poursuivons notre
émission tout de suite avec le chiffre
de la semaine
30% c'est la part des femmes créatrices
d'entreprises en France parmi les
entrepreneurs un nombre qui évolue peu
depuis de nombreuses années environ 170
000 entreprises ont été créées en 2011
par des femmes soient 32% des nouvelles
unités et les mamans entrepreneurs
françaises sont parmi les mers les plus
actifs d'Europe avec un taux d'activité
de plus de 80% pour les mamans d'un
enfant on estime à 190 000 le nombre
d'entreprises créées par des femmes dont
120 000 en auto-entreprises et 70 000
entreprises traditionnelles je vous
propose maintenant de passer à notre
portrait de la semaine
Doro c'est une entreprise suédoise
internationale dirigée par un Français
Jérôme Arnaud elle commercialise des
téléphones depuis 2010 après avoir
acheté racheté pardon une des filières
de Matra à Montigny-le-Bretonneux depuis
2007 le groupe s'est lancé dans le
mobile pour senior un tournant
commercial amorcé par le français j'ai
romarino après avoir été président de la
branche française il a été nommé
président de ce groupe international
pour mener cette reconversion à succès
nous l'avons rencontré voici son
portrait Elodie moine et Romain ruspini
vous l'aurez peut-être deviné à son
accent Jérôme Arnaud n'est pas américain
ni même anglais et encore moins suédois
pourtant il est le président de Doro un
groupe scandinaves international à la
tête d'une entreprise de taille
intermédiaire il dirige une centaine
d'employés de ces bureaux de Montigny
les branches françaises allemandes
anglaises italiennes et suédoise ne
m'ont pas refusé parce que j'étais
français on va dire ça comme ça c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est assez unique
d'être président de ce côté suédoise
français
le groupe de rose c'est le leader sur le
marché du mobile pour seniors depuis sa
création le groupe a vendu plus de 6
millions de ces téléphones des
smartphones disposant des dernières
technologies mais avec une utilisation
très simplifiée un tournant pour
entreprise amorcé par Jérôme Arnaud en
2007 donc un moment important j'ai
proposé de développer l'activité seniors
et suite à une récapitalisation
d'entreprise au niveau de la Suède le
Conseil AD m'a proposé de prendre la
présidence du groupe pour développer
cette réorientation senior pour
l'ensemble de la société d'origine
bordelaise il sort diplômé de l'École
Centrale à Paris en 1986 il travaille
ensuite pour Matra au début de sa
carrière une ascension professionnelle
progressive à travers différentes
entreprises à cette époque-là c'était
Matra vous laisser se défaire de son
activité terminée résidentiel ce qui a
été fait avec la société Doro qui en a
fait l'acquisition au 1er janvier 2000
et ce faisant la cité de Rome a demandé
de prendre en charge l'activité France
et donc de transformer cette division de
Matra en une société filiale d'un groupe
suédois devenu PDG du groupe Jérôme
Arnaud a conservé ses bureaux ici à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les 25 employés
le connaissent depuis ses débuts en 2000
aujourd'hui il travaille à côté du PDG
du groupe alors forcément cela favorise
les échanges
à Françoise
sais-tu que j'ai à nouveau projet je
voudrais que nous puissions faire une
demande de droit à la prise électrique
pour pouvoir connecter des voitures
électriques sur le parking et quand on
leur demande si avoir un PDG français
facilite les choses oui ça va éviter
déjà à prendre le Suédois j'ai de bonnes
choses et
non non c'est vrai que c'est très
appréciable et la Jérôme depuis
longtemps donc c'est vrai que c'est pour
nous c'est une continuité et au
contraire on en est fier parce qu'en
fait il était président de France avant
de redirection du groupe donc pour nous
c'est porté valeur aussi de la France à
l'étranger donc c'est bien aussi porter
un groupe international de cette taille
de mon souplesse et adaptation chaque
pays ne travaille pas de la même façon
il faut fait Derrer les employés dans
une même démarche les Suédois sont très
pragmatiques vont avancer de manière
très coordonnée notamment avec nos
bureaux en Chine
vont les Français vont avoir tout le
dynamisme et pousser un peu dans les
limites les Allemands à la fois la force
de leur marché et des rôles
blanc et tout ça fait que ça fonctionne
et tout le monde arrive à se faire
confiance et sans trop de près de
préjugés et ça c'est assez important
l'entreprise s'adresse au marché mondial
des bureaux s'ouvrent régulièrement un
peu partout dans le monde sous le regard
attentif du président entre mobilité et
décalage horaire le quotidien du PDG
s'organise souvent entre deux avions
c'est une question de d'équilibre on mes
enfants sont grands donc
l'essentiel c'est de se retrouver en
effet les week-ends mais oui c'est
important en tout cas de savoir ménager
sa monture et de d'avoir soit des
activités sportives ou autre pour tenir
le choc à 51 ans le chef d'entreprise a
réussi la transition du groupe Doro une
niche sur un marché international qu'il
souhaite développer là on se diversifie
en ajoutant l'ordinateur à notre gamme
nous aurons bientôt une tablette pour
également aller vers la convergence
numérique de l'ensemble des produits en
2013 le chiffre d'affaires de Doro était
de plus de 133 millions d'euros une
augmentation de 46, 8% par rapport à
2012 Jérôme Arnaud espère que ses
nouveaux produits rencontreront le même
succès que ces smartphones il peut y
croire le marché des seniors étant plein
développement en France on recense 20
millions de personnes de plus de 50 ans
soient un tiers de la population
il est maintenant temps de passer à
notre agenda de la semaine
cette semaine deux rendez-vous à ne pas
manquer la Cité des Métiers de Trappes
organisent mercredi 12 novembre de 14h à
16h une réunion sur les métiers de
l'armée de terre elle sera animée par la
surface de Versailles le secteur cherche
à recruter 10 000 personnes dont 400
métiers différents n'oubliez pas de vous
inscrire auprès de la Cité des Métiers
vous souhaitez monter votre propre
entreprise et vous vous posez des
questions sur le financement de vos
projets un atelier sur le thème du
financement de son entreprise et
proposer par la Maison de l'Entreprise
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est un
atelier gratuit qui se déroule le jeudi
13 novembre de 14h30 à 17h là aussi il
faut s'inscrire
merci de nous avoir suivis je vous donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de fileco je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée